en vídeos anteriores encontramos una
expresión para la corriente y en un
circuito el s como este y lo que
encontramos fue que y es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de la capacitancia entre la
inductancia por el voltaje inicial de 0
por el seno de omega 0 t omega 0 es la
frecuencia natural y dijimos que omega 0
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 1 entre l
por ser de 0 es el voltaje inicial en el
capacitor y en nuestra su posición
original dijimos que la corriente
iniciaba en 0 y esta es la expresión
para la corriente ahora vamos a realizar
un ejemplo en específico que dibujaré
aquí abajo primero vamos a poner un
interruptor de manera que podamos
agregar energía que no se vaya de aquí
se va a ser igual a un cuarto de un faro
y eleva a ser igual a un henry y en el
capacitor voy a poner la carga
suficiente para llegar a 10 volts antes
de que cerremos el interruptor y cuando
te es igual a 0 cerramos el interruptor
y queremos encontrar ahí
dt tenemos a l tenemos hacer tenemos un
voltaje inicial por lo que tenemos todo
lo necesario para encontrar la corriente
primero vamos a encontrar a omega 0
omega 0 es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 1
entre l por c que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 1 entre l es un henri por sé
que es un cuarto de farah esto es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 4 que es igual a 2
que es igual a 2 y esto tiene unidades
de radiales por segundo esta es la
frecuencia natural ya tenemos la
frecuencia natural y podemos calcular lo
demás y es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
un cuarto de farah entre un henri por
1000 es igual a 10 volts
seno de omega 0 t omega 0 es 2 por t
finalmente y va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de un cuarto o un medio un
medio por 10 5 y es igual a 5 por el
seno de 2 t así que para este circuito
en específico esta es la respuesta para
esta corriente de acá y les voy a
mostrar cómo luce esto
esta es una gráfica de iu de t igual a 5
por el seno de 2 t y así luce esta onda
seno
aquí tenemos este eje del tiempo en
segundos y en este otro eje tenemos los
amperes que va desde los 5 amperes hasta
los menos 5 amperes y continúa así para
siempre y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
encontrar el voltaje en el circuito aún
no hemos hablado del voltaje vamos a
dibujar de nuevo el circuito aquí y aquí
tenemos el voltaje entre estos dos nodos
ya encontramos ahí y ahora queremos
encontrar a b sabemos que es igual a 5
por el seno de 2 t y para encontrar a b1
formas más sencillas es usar la ecuación
del inductor
sabemos que ve es igual a él por de y dt
es la ecuación básica y ve del inductor
de es igual a l él es uno por del dt que
es de dt de 5 por el seno de 2 t
lo escribimos por acá me es igual 5 sale
de la derivada por la derivada del seno
de 2 t y la derivada del seno de 2 t es
2 por el coseno de 2 t por lo que la
solución para nuestro voltaje es 10 por
el coseno de 2 t aquí ocurrió algo
interesante comenzamos con la corriente
siendo una onda c no después tomamos la
derivada de esa corriente de esa función
seno y obtuvimos una función coseno así
que pasamos de seno a coseno para el
voltaje lo que significa que el voltaje
no luce igual a la corriente ahora
veamos una gráfica del voltaje
este es el voltaje btt que encontramos
es igual a 10 coseno de 2 t comienza con
un valor de 10 cuando te es igual a 0 y
forma una onda coseno sube y baja entre
10 y menos 10 volts
ahora veamos cómo luce la gráfica tanto
de y como debe en el mismo lugar y
podemos ver la relación temporal entre
ellas
esta es la gráfica de iu de té en azul y
verde t en anaranjado la corriente es la
onda seno y el voltaje es la onda coseno
y esto es lo que buscamos la respuesta
natural de un circuito lc y aquí tenemos
los valores específicos de los dos
componentes y vimos que pudimos
encontrar la corriente y el voltaje
ambos lucen como onda senoidal es y es
de aquí de donde salen las ondas
senoidal es en la electrónica lo que es
bastante genial